again this is really the fighter in the
kid come on
baby play with toys that I can't afford
we're I play with toys so wait you were
telling me well I I was telling you hold
on we'll get that what's up everybody
this is the first ever live firing the
kid yeah and Brennan's been saying the
most off-color [__] to try to get it out
of his body you see we're 5 seconds in
you've already cussed I didn't this is
why we can't go live oh I'm not allowed
to this is part of the problem oh you're
not allowed to cuss no you shouldn't
they cat you in the first few minutes
I'll say things like golly gosh and
shoot cheese and
rice mother father but the thing is when
we go live it's not so much on the
companions because that's different but
with this you you can't say certain
stuff but it's like I was telling you
it's like when you're a kid and they go
don't touch that button you're like why
not yeah that's how I feel right it's
the it's the it's as the oldest story on
the planet at least for the West is well
you're in the Garden of Eden
everything's perfect now there's a tree
over there just don't eat that Apple
whatever you do how long can you last
I'm the type of guy I like to see the
apple and then if it's in my face long
it's forbidden fruit I mean part of the
fun is I get to dip my toe in a pool of
sin yeah I feel I feel I can't be I just
feel dangerous when we go live dude I
don't know if we're Made for This Wait
tell me about you were telling me a
story I tell it like in this crazy
Mustang in this crazy Mustang and the
owner how much was it $650,000 Mustang
it's a $650,000 Mustang all carbon fiber
Elanor Mustang oh carbon fiber of course
and it has a it has a button on the
stick shift that says around it just
like the moveie says Go baby go and has
a red button wait it has a it has a
button on the stick shift on the stick
shift and you hit it just likeit but is
it a manual stick shift manual yeah yeah
stick shift right because automatics
don't have stick shift okay shut up I
know how to drive a stick shift you know
that yeah I'm old enough I learned you
know how you uh prevent someone from
stealing your car how by a manual that's
right cuz those dummy stealing cars
can't they don't have to drive manual
cuz they're morons right but so that he
has the red button says Go baby go
around it it says Go baby go and we're
in it I was like what's that button for
and he's like ju just don't push that
I'm like yeah no doubt and driving was
like what's what's that button do though
man he's like dude it would caused a lot
of problems if you push that button I
was like I want to push that button oh
daddy wants to push that button well
what happens do Fire come out the back
no it gives it a shot of nitrous but
apparently the engine wasn't tuned for
it yet so if you push it ruin the engine
ruin the engine yeah I want to push it
bad yeah I want to push it so bad really
nitrous you know what this ride needs a
shot of nitrous that's just different
level I just I just but like how I was
just looking at the Plaid Tesla sure
just bust off the line bust off the line
yeah how is that not how does that not
excite [__] it's a th over a th
horsepower I mean it beats any of your
cars no I'm actually racing one coming
up no it destroys your cars you know
that yeah you know that the
Plaid which car which car are you
putting up he bring up 0 to 60 in the
Plaid what car are you bring stupid this
is fun to educate you though what car
are you what car are you putting up
against the Plaid cuz Rogan called me
and goes all the the cars are stupid
this car is insane well he's been
compromised by the left well no that's
not fair it's a 1.99 second what 1.9 how
could you ever beat that hey chin do me
a favor can you bring up a demon 170 0
to 60 this
demon can figure things out in life what
do you mean a demon 170 you saw my green
car out there right the sublime green
yeah I saw that that's dude it hey when
I say there's not a car for
you well it does
it does make a they shouldn't sell it to
you well I you you pulled out of the
thing I went like this I went like this
I went hey it caught me hey you old can
you read that with
1,025 horsepower wow 060 time in 1.66
seconds now what was your what was your
cuck Tesla all right 1.99 seconds so
that's eternity you're 33 seconds Brian
if I run a if I run the 40 and a 43 and
you run a 46 you know how much faster I
am than you
those seconds are
everything God forbid God forbid you
don't get there 33 seconds faster than
I'd even bring this up you're the one
that's like this this Tesla plat is
insane have you driven this thing I love
people these things are insane have you
driven themad it's like the power's just
there I don't speak like that okay
everyone that drives Tesla talks like
that so that that green monstrosity that
I heard the other day was
like like I was at Awan which is as
Progressive they sell camel milk camel
milk for $32 a gallon if you want it if
you want camel milk which by the way
when you drink camel milk they'll tell
you any bed will tell you you're going
to have the runs no matter who you are
at first it takes your body a while you
know you look like a camel
yeah what what you as you're saying
camel milk I'm like as you're talking
like man Brian looks very similar to C I
have a very straight dude you look myse
no your entire C is very my neck is a
little long and my nose I no forget
about the neck your face that's so
obnoxious I have I do have a problematic
nose wow dude that's cool no my nose in
the morning my nose is my nose takes up
most of my face dude all right dude you
camel no I have you're saying I have the
coloring no you have the same setup
facial features as a camel chin you
don't have to [__] get the closeup
I'm just looking around that's all right
now bring up my face oh gosh very
similar to oh God you have camel Vibes
dude can't see it's not a bad thing you
I don't need a lot of water I'll admit
and it's hard to get water into my face
as you get older it becomes harder no
you know what you look like you look
like Jay-Z and white face that's a good
picture I'm really handsome there yeah
that's fake though right so go to a
current one where he looks like a camel
me with my eyes when I have my lid
surgery this is closer I'm a good cute
kid there dude you look like camel you
look like Jay-Z and white face Jay-Z
looks like a camel I'm not even going to
touch that um yeah there I am there's
old camel boy I miss that jacket it's
nice to see jacket what happened to that
jacket I lost it you were cute in that
yeah that's a Vince jacket man what
happened to my jacket oh remember we
used to go to Vince all the time off of
uh AB Ken are they there anymore had
when we had the Abbot Kenny Fight Club
which we can't talk about a lot first R
of Fight Club yeah and a lot of people
don't know that we used to have the
Abbot keny Fight Club and people thought
it was just a coffee Club what what it
really was was we used to meet and we
used to there we used to fight there was
a room and we would actually fight it
it'd be me and Brian versus Will Sasso
and we'd beat the [__] out of them yeah
until will got mad then he would he
would tear us he'd grab us like Bam Bam
and and just start throwing us against
the wall but we did a lot of fighting
back
then look at that you and your brother
that was when you were fighting that's
right in fight days man that's old
school wow I feel like your brother is
taller than that uh yeah I don't know he
looked short there in his haircut he's
on a lower yeah he is he his foot here
is that a celebrity shot
that was when you were fighting those
were the days dude those were the
freaking days that was when you were
miserable training all the time H yeah
no you weren't miserable but I wasn't
miserable that's a heavy word now
there's a lot of chat on the on the oh
yeah we have make on the entanet that
want me to make the announcement that
we're going live today to announce that
we're stopping the show yeah so I think
it's important right now to to say as
we're live that um we've been doing this
for over 12 years over 12 years we've
had an amazing slowly morphing into a
camel yep and we've had an amazing run
and I think everything does come to an
end it does you know everything
ultimately comes to an end except for
fighter and the kid cuz we're never
stopping this we're going to do this
until when I'm 70 when I'm 80 and I have
to take my dentures and take them out of
a glass on the show I'm going ride I'm
going to ride you like a desert camel
dude till the end you know what I hope I
outlive you because will you know what I
mean I'm going to be an old you're going
to see me caressing your dying face and
I'm going to be like shouldn't have done
so much of all the stuff you did just
all the stuff you're just big you got
hey you had a good run you were big and
big dogs die ear what a weird it's weird
I mean but that's probably that's the
way you said it that's them the way you
said it sounded like we were ending I
when you made that announcement also
6:30 in the morning I know but have more
animation don't be as puffy in your face
you sucked in that you were not good I
even told him I I left him me I was like
hey dude be be a little more animated
like I I hated your stupid announcement
and it sounds like you're saying like
who he viral the kid well everybody
thinks you quit comedy and everybody
thinks you quit that how about that went
viral on Bloody elbow well they're the
ultimate Trolls but that they do they
they're just trolls I don't I don't I
don't mind them but
they yeah I'm not quitting I I just I'm
not going to Toronto I'm not going to
the east coast I've set next week we
have I mean we have a a show in uh
August I'm I'm sorry in Austin we have a
show February 15th in aw live show with
some probably some very special big
guest kids going live saying it's one
night only one show only one show Vulcan
gas company the mothership uh stepmom
yeah we're at the Vulcan gas company at
10 p.m. one show only fire and kid live
10 p.m. one show resy there we have yeah
we want to start doing once a month fire
and kid live the the energy the comedy
energy is in Austin no matter what
people say thank you to Joe Rogan and a
lot of other people so there's a lot of
the energy is where we go Brian thank
you thank you we'll see yeah I know
Energy's a little low right now but
you're old so I'll take a couple of old
guys yeah getting but I uh yeah that the
quitting the I don't even see how that
makes the rounds because if you listen
to the PO chin was there chin did you
ever hear me say I quit comedy no no I
said I'm taking a break I'm juggling too
many things in the road beats when he
says a break though it's 5 years and
plus your daughter I mean like what do
you expect how is your daughter doing
she's doing better finally sleeping she
can breathe better still not a hundo so
she's a little fighter though she'll get
there but way better way better you tell
she's happy that was a lot more Touch
and Go than we let on oh man a lot it
was a lot more Touch and Go than anybody
that we cuz you know it's hard to talk
about that stuff or even like you don't
want to say anything but it was it was
bad bad no you never know what's going
to happen people kept asking me how you
know it's like and I was like it's not
it's not good you know no it was a tough
time which ain't good when when you call
me and you say I'm in the hospital again
cuz my child's having trouble breathing
breathing or can't breathe yeah yeah
that was dicey and they couldn't figure
it out but uh no as far as the standup
and all that stuff goes I just juggle a
million things and the road just you
know you're you got to so I mean you
understand this and a lot of uh the
viewers understand this but when you're
doing standup like you're doing sets at
night during the week Monday through
Wednesday and then you're on tour
Thursday Friday Saturday then you're
home Sunday yeah I just can't I can't do
that schedule with everything I have
going on and then also on hold on and
then also my son's football coach
baseball coach that's what you that's
that's that to me is the real reason you
love coaching your kids love it
absolutely love it hate missing it can't
miss that but then also I got a you know
I just got a lot going on and it's okay
to step to just kind of step back from
one thing do this thing step back I can
go in and out I feel like if I gave you
if I said hey here's this here's enough
money that you're set for life you would
uh there's a good chance you would
literally never leave your home or the
fields on which your children are
playing yeah good chance that's still
podcast though that's still podcast yeah
maybe you might but I think I would what
what you do yeah when they're at school
and they're getting older what do you do
yeah yeah but no I love it absolutely
love it yeah yeah it's a good time yeah
know but it just showed like but we've
known this everyone knows this like the
the fake news out there like that's more
interesting than Brendan's daughter's
sick so he's stepping back for St to
focus on family that's not a headline
no that's not that doesn't get clicks no
but you know they they got a business to
run so they got to do their thing
there's just so much fake news like it's
it's all with in it left right
entertainment like that stuff is Click
baiting the YouTube thumbnails podcast
with Peter Zion and uh he said that in
on his Twitter he's got a literally the
first 10 suggestions on news are are
either Uh Russian or Chinese Bots like
it's all troll Farms so he's got on his
ex so he's got to he's got to figure out
a way to get past that to get to the
real news just finding when he says
figure out does he just scroll down well
just finding what's right what's real
and what's not is a is a [__] right now
insane it's insane especially with the
election coming up it's like man the
fake news is going get I know but then
when people start talking about what
they want to do for it they don't know
uh like people are like well no
censorship okay I know I agree but we
got to do something you know cuz right
now when I see something now literally I
go I don't know
I don't know I me too right away when I
see I'm like even if I see a video I'm
like me too I'm like I got cont yeah cuz
they were doing that to Rogan you know
they were like um of course they they
they different companies are literally
using AI to get it to make it sound like
he's endorsing their product so my
friend's dad did I tell you this yeah
you said this twice on the Pod okay I'll
take it bought a CPAC some kind of [__]
yeah but they're doing they're doing
that with everybody I mean especially
Rogan how famous is Rogan they're doing
it with everybody he's not the only one
they got to figure out how to control
that though they have to yeah but it's
also like it leaks into other things too
like with I'm not sure if you saw the
news with Dustin por like his fight was
called off so Dana announces it I don't
know if you're following this so Dana
announces right him versus our boy St
Denise which is an insane fight for UFC
299 Dana announces it so if it comes
from Dana who's the you know the CEO of
the UFC you assume it's real yeah assume
it's going down it's keyed in locked in
we can Bank on this and then it comes
out Dustin por is like I never agreed to
that fight oh wow he's like I never said
that oh wow he's like I didn't agree to
that so then he called it off Dustin
posted like he not find him never agreed
to it never came to terms so the fight's
off then hours later he's like my bat
miscommunication I talked to my manager
the fight's back on yeah they're but
what's going on there is and this is why
it's tough this is where it comes to the
fake news and what Dana does does is and
think about this is he applies pressure
that's the fight he wants to make
Dustin's going wait for me to fight this
monster nobody really knows I need a bag
and Dana's going no no this what we're
giving you and Dustin's like I'm not
doing it for that he announces the fight
so the pressures on DP Dustin por to
take the fight otherwise the fan base is
going to think he's the one that yo you
don't want to fight him you're scared
plan a fighter so so it's it's Dana it's
a t it's a bullying tactic that's gone
on forever they did it with uh Brady
they've done it with so many fighters
where they announ all the time cuz now
the pressure's on you wow cuz then then
the UFC goes look you don't want to
fight we offered him a fight and you're
like whoa I was negotiating so what DP
did this is brilliant What Dustin pory
did he was asking for this much money
they went no but they he knows they
announced the fight so he goes cool you
don't want to give me that money cool
fight hey guys never agree to it fight's
actually off I've never signed a
contract then UFC goes whoa whoa here's
your money he goes hey fight's back on
okay so it's DP but he's a legend so he
most do it screws when Dana goes hey
this fight's happen you're like this me
I just found out about this yeah he does
it all it's a form of bullying basically
well it's that I've heard I remember
back in the day a certain fighter who
you know very well he couldn't make the
weight like it was like he was amazing
fighter and he was like I can't no they
were like well you'll get cut you know
now I don't know if that was Dana that
was somebody over but what's that yeah
well in other words they taking the
fight taking the fight but that's
different you're taking the fight though
but that's different the fighter if he
can't make the weight that I mean you
got to make the weight dude if you
agreed to the weight well he are you
saying it short notice short notice
there he was like I don't want to fight
that guy I'm ready you're talking about
Weidman I'm talking about somebody else
when he lost all that weight I'm talking
about somebody else but you know I don't
yeah but yeah I don't know I was there
that's different than this this is this
is them going hey look who's fighting
announcing it promot they actually
announced it they announced while they
were negotiating or they only had a
verbal agreement from one side of the
Party St Denise and po was like n man I
need more money they go nope it's UFC
299 you're doing it he they do it all
the time and then the media reports it
and Dan's like look at these SLE balls
it's like well dude you're the one that
told us it's
happening so it's just a form of
bullying basically because then it puts
all the pressure on Dustin porier well
and then here's the problem yeah or it's
or it's a form of
business like I don't I I don't surpris
Bad Business suris bad business I mean
that's horrible business but you get
away with a lot right cuz he's what are
you going to do it's Dana White that's
what I'm saying you get away with it if
you can get away with it as a if that's
so the UFC is the star the one thing
that that Dana W's done very well is
making sure that everybody knows you may
be a great fighter you may have a
following but make no mistake this is
the this is the UFC show this is not
maybe the exception is Conor McGregor
but even con but that's all by Design
that's all by Design smart right smart
that's what I'm saying is good business
like you never are beholden to one
individual because human beings are way
too fickle Fighters injuries and all
that UFC is the brand yeah yeah does
just because good business doesn't mean
uh it's it's the right thing to do right
it's not the right thing to do announce
in a fight to force a Fighter's hand you
are you speaking out of turn do you know
this for for a fact is what I'm saying
for a fact okay for a fact okay oh you
oh you think I made this up they've done
this to me personally yeah oh you think
this is just a whim well I don't know oh
no this is the I want to make sure you
you know about this specifically with
Dustin since we're live and we're
talking okay oh you oh hilar oh that's
cuz you're not following the news no
this is out be this is this is this has
been out yeah no I'm saying okay you
have privy information everyone knows
this what I'm saying is not breaking
news this is probably a day old but we
weren't allowed to do the podcast cuz
you were gone so this is old like this
is not new this is all
what's public is that he said I didn't
agree with this fight and then he said
it's back on obviously something
happened behind the scenes No no no
there's journalists I'm not a journalist
there's journalists way above me where I
get my information yeah who are in the
spot right got it and and so that's what
I'm saying yeah you you have privy
information yeah this isn't like yeah
well no what what is what I'm saying is
not in the news necessarily is saying
the specifics of what you just said
which is that I'm going to announce this
DUS was like we're in negotiations what
are you doing and then he goes I'm not
going to do it that's that's what I
don't think is as clear so that's new to
me to you yes to the fight fans they're
familiar with this story
maybe hanani reported this two days ago
so he's saying exactly what you're
saying correct all right all right there
you
go interesting interesting interesting
yeah but it's a tactic they've done for
I mean it just forces the Fighter's hand
yeah cuz then you know it makes DP look
bad and imagine you know you're a fan of
him you buy tickets travel and then the
fight's not for and this guy saying
Denise is a nightmare we'll see he
hasn't faced any Elite competition like
DP so we're going to find out right you
know like he hasn't beat any like top 15
guys so this is his first big test
okay it's a huge jump for him huge jump
he's a Savage he has all the makings of
and that's probably why they they gave
him to Dustin see I don't know why I I I
I don't know I don't know for Dustin
it's a you know it's a such a risk well
it's also weird though because a lot of
people don't know s Den right so it's
like why you know what I mean it's like
it's I mean it's Winn for the UFC The
House Always Wins it's a win-win for the
UFC because what the UFC is doing is all
right how many fights Dustin have left
he's talking about retiring he's talking
about not only doing big fights so I he
might might only have one or two left
all right well we want to build St
Denise he seems to be the next guy we
don't know so let's have him fight DP
before he leaves y wow which I'm DP I
you know that's why he's Dustin por but
yeah I don't see there's not a huge
upside because you beat him everyone
goes yeah he havn't beat anybody man you
know he's he's not that good did you see
the uh the tweets this is this is a good
example of whether or not this was fake
news or not did you see the tweets that
uh um ma Max Holloway and Justin Gage
uh were tweeting did you see how
convoluted they were did you see those
what do you mean like they were tweeting
at each other but it was so
discombobulated like I couldn't
understand what they were saying they
saying it's like CT oh dude but I mean
or or they were just on their in their
car talking or something but and it and
they just hit send you got to see this I
have it I actually can send it to you
chin I can send you the uh it's them
like talking about their fight yeah dude
it's nuts I was like missell
yeah
nuts it's just them going back on text
like just or their little
videos we live B this is stuff go on
keep I'm looking I'm talking right now
um I'm gonna find this because it was
really wild I was like what if you just
go to Max Holloway's Twitter chin and
then search through his replies it it
come up instead of Brian s to you
waiting for
that all right replies you said um I
would assume all right let try it I just
sent
Justin I'll just sent it to you Brian
just sent me live oh it says Instagram
but let's
see yeah what is your uh but if you
repli we can just see it CH if you just
scroll down but was
time guys just enjoy your uh enjoy your
fruit compo as we go through
this uh there you go brother you know
don't when hit I and knock down who to
title Vegas remember to the chin I
remember wow okay Casey's laughing there
Las Vegas War does doesn't know that
when octagon can we so when want to
slugfest drop hurt first yes so baddest
Meer now is this fake news it feels like
it's fake dude I feel like it's fake
that's why I'm saying go to Max always
replies we on it so we can see but let's
search for it because we can see heated
trash TR between Max and Justin please
check into Dr Las Vegas War doesn't know
that when octagon oh look but look Max
put you can't be serious like it's fake
okay yeah that that's just them that's
just some yeah my friend's like check
this out CT I'm like I don't know dude
but you fell for it I didn't fall for it
I was like um yeah I didn't even see
that guys I just want can I just shout
out the fact that people are probably
going what is going on with Brian's Body
why does he look that good or they're
saying man those guys are dressing
pretty swaggy today well that also but
also like why do those jeans hug his his
crazy crazy Apple thighs they're tight I
got some apple thighs in an apple bottom
that's from squats that's from that's
the first thing I hit when I train is my
legs
but well true classic jeans if you let
me if You' let me make true classic
jeans that you know for me it's like
they hug my chest hug my arms a little
loose here yeah we always do there's
always I always have something true
Classic on because um all my merch is
true classic yeah like if you buy a
thick boy anything off the site
everything's true Classic this is true
classic sweater that's the true classic
sweater this is like the Brian K starter
pack holds on to your body though holds
to your body I love those they got all
these sweaters they're then the price
point swag the price point is right and
they got that moisture wicking they got
this these new t-shirts that I wear
t-shirt everyone asked me when I wear
those white shirts everyone's like
where'd you get that shirt it's only
true classic merch on the road if it's a
plain colored shirt with gray blue black
green look at this waffle white yeah
it's it's always true classic they're
literally next door yeah I know they
provide all CEO we see them all the time
yeah they're the best yeah we rock all
their stuff and now they're on the show
and they have this new moisture wicking
uh Odor Control these shirts where where
they you know when you wear them you for
working out you don't smell in them and
they've got these Ultra Soft super
stretchy joggers yeah they got they got
shirts jog I love their joggers they got
hoodies they got button-ups their jeans
are great try their jeans because their
jeans are the highest quality but they
also have the stretchy tight ones and
they have the loose ones like those yeah
like those yeah you like them tighter I
like your little little TI I like them a
little looser yeah so we should trade
you're a little bigger yeah these aren't
going to fit you there's a there's a one
of the guys who works for us is awesome
and I um Mark I said to him U is it Mark
Mark yeah let's finish the read though
before you go on the I said to him I
said you know you should get some true
classic cuz he saw my jeans he goes I
want to get those I go you what 32 32 he
goes no I'm a I'm a I'm a 3430 and I was
like 32 and I was like nah you're a
3232 and he's like no I'm not he's like
that's not what I wear man I was like I
know what his lower body is about um
yeah but true class I I'm giving a
little why are you guys laughing in the
back cuz they know it's so bad listen to
me upgrade your closet 25% off you get
25 % off your first order all right so
whatever it is you can make 2024 I'm
telling you if you wear these you'll
always wear them I'm wearing their
underweare which I never I I have all
their underwear true classic.com fighter
save up to 25% off your first order I
promise you the best PL shirts
button-ups jeans everything sweaters
hoodies joggers they got all true
classic.com fighter you get 25% off your
first order true classic you got some
fieldcraft gear in bro oh dude do I have
fieldcraft gear tell us what it is
before you start showing it off Mike
lover who was a Green Beret and then did
other things in the military you're
welcome yeah high level 18 years in the
US Army yeah smarter [__] and everything
else so I know about this stuff I'm
going to show you this stuff that we get
you just carry this in your car all
right it's just it's you got gloves you
got you got trauma bandage it's little
things like this somebody gets stabbed
somebody gets shot the first thing that
they do a medic will do is put a
pressure you got to you got to equalize
the pressure on your body what kills you
is that you cannot regulate the pressure
of your body so you if you don't have
one of those that can save a life right
away
tourniquets tourniquets biggest thing in
the world had haven't taken them out of
the bag yet it just looks all the same
well okay this is awesome I like this
they got a they got this this is best
fcra I'm going feel survival they got
they got they got this they but you got
to go you got to train on this stuff
they got a freaking a fire starter yeah
you want a fire starter I'll start I'll
light you on fire right now dude all
right they got that I love that I carry
this in my car I'm just showing you what
I carry um they also have tourniquet so
when you when you get when you're
bleeding okay you can tie your arm off
you get shot or something people tie
their arm off you can you can go for
eight hours you can literally and not
bleed out and not die that there are a
lot of stories about guys who tied a
tourniquet around their arm because they
were bleeding so bad or around their leg
and they were able to fight on in combat
for eight more hours and if you want an
app that explains it better than Brian
uh field survival fieldcraft survival
app will have an intro level education
that builds into advanced topics so no
one is left out um the fieldcraft
survival digital app contains longterm
educational content for all things to
get you ready for whatever the situation
is tactical self-defense Jiu-Jitsu metal
medical survival Bushcraft family stuff
disaster emergency blankets everything
man you beginner to advance they cover
each topic structured MCH Master Class
style format to help you whatever your
skill set is so you're more prepared you
are your own First Response that's the
bigest thing is that mike always says
you are your first response like if
you're expecting a government agency to
come to your that's great you're you're
going to wait 20 minutes a half hour and
well they say with cops you got to be
able to defend yourself at least six
minutes you're going to save your own
life you you are your first response and
chances are you're going to sa the way
you're the one who's going to save your
own life do not wait for somebody you
will sink to the level of your training
that's the other thing that mike always
talks about and these guys always talk
about it's not that hard just go to the
website and look at how to tie a
tourniquet that can save somebody's
lifecraft survival y.com chin fighter
fieldcraft survival.com
fighter be your own first responder man
monthly you get a subscription get 30
days free just use the code fighter 30
or the annual subscription 35% off
annual subscription use the code fighter
35 yep don't sing to the level of
training but have some training it's not
that hard good awesome start a fire I
got it' be funny if I just carry this
stuff around but this is always in my
car just carry a box around with me like
this
m um how's Dallas buddy Dallas is great
Dallas is always good man Dallas is
Texas is a it's a large Place big yeah
like it's as big how big is Texas Texas
is that the biggest state or is
California the biggest state isn't Texas
Texas [__] nuts California's bigger
right there are more tigers and lions in
Texas than I think like literally Alaska
Alaska's couple one two dumb asses right
I didn't know
thatas but so much of Alaska's like I
mean come on you know I didn't know was
four okay so Alaska Texas Texas is
[__] huge huge California Montana
yeah I didn't either boy Alaska's so
much bigger than everywhere else yeah a
lot of that Nevada Arizona a lot of that
desert right a lot of that [__] is like
you know California yeah unless you're
an aner you got
nothing
um yeah but Texas was fun yeah I like
Texas I like Texas I feel safer in Texas
do you I do I think it's because they
just did a study um I think because Pete
you're allowed to carry there and I
always feel like if somebody comes in
and starts blasting somebody in the
restaurant's going to take them out like
so they found that um they did this
study this meta study about the minute
said when in certain states where you're
allowed to carry uh you know I think
Colin no about it just on yeah which the
idea oh crime's going to go up homicide
no they actually went down yeah I don't
want to get into why but it's but that's
interesting to me so I always feel I
don't know something about Texas it just
feels more it just feels Freer it just
really does which is why people are
going I feel free pretty much everywhere
I go it's cuz you're so big and strong
cuz you have the privilege of size
sizeist yeah I don't I don't feel yeah I
don't I don't land in text I'm like oh
man I feel
free like we're like we're shunned here
you know or like yeah yeah I know what
you mean yeah hey I mean hey hey hey
take you got to start with the fact that
we're all privileged Americans let's
just do that when you pray if you pray
start by just just thanking God that
you're American that you were born in
America cuz there are place you could be
born was so much worse so let's just
start with that um all right what do you
got Chen all right first one is Alyssa
Milano is begin to Flack from fans
because she opened up a GoFundMe to help
pay for her son's like baseball team she
did yeah so this is the GoFundMe
here she's just not reading the so my
son's in travel team it it is expensive
right but especially where her son play
plays which I know where he plays that
those parents you know they're pretty
well off in that area I just don't think
she's um reading the room right even if
she you know she wanted to help out the
team is it is it's expensive to go
especially that at Cooperstown so you
know the travel she's just using her
she's using her platform to raise money
for the team yeah that's fair you're
talking I'm sure they travel like 12 to
15 kids parents flights hotels she's
just doing the I bet someone was like
hey can you tweet this out so he hit the
Gund me they did hit the Gund me but
someone should have been like man it's
going me a bad luck like you know cuz
she's a celebrity who knows her
financial situation you'd hope she's
good but I agree what's this hey thanks
for helping abandoned dog so those are
replies to her but it's it's hope your
mother has who has a net worth of $10
million donated to the shelter shut up
also knowing she has this money she
could not be asking middle- inome people
for decided to donate a baseball team to
a baseball team but this is her son go
go you do realize I'm only 12 yeah [__]
off hey IA stallion whatever the hell
you are shut up yeah God man find
another find another bad guy I know she
she just asked for when celebrities
asked like remember when The Rock and
Oprah asked for money with uh Hawaii and
you're like hey man the two of you have
like at least a billion dollars between
the two of you they're just asking for
donations that was weird it's always
weird just know that you're going to
take Flack for that you got to be more
yeah yeah also but that she's allowed to
raise money using her platform for her I
don't I she should have went a different
direction about it but also but now
she's putting attention on the team and
her kid like you're asking for this yeah
hey get off his page he's 12 thank you
like what do you want him to do now new
I got to talk to you about uh good news
is they did raise the money yeah they
they hit the they they asked for 10
grand they got 12 kids on a traveling
baseball team that's big too it's
expensive it's a lot of yeah yeah but
yeah she needs to read the room of
course this backlash was going to happen
yeah oh have you seen this no dude
they're going to do a so Olympic style
competition called allows performance
enhancing drugs the enhanced games let
the games begin oh my God I'm the
fastest man in the
world we can't play this Jen I'm worried
he's broken you you play a little bit of
it I am a proud enhanced athlete I'm a
we have important allies in our battle
for bodily Freedom as we build the first
sporting event that allows performance
enhancements and pays all a just say
steroids you [__] what do you mean I
love how we play around with language
yes no no you're allowed to take
steroids could be on EPO there's a lot
of stuff awesome yeah I can't wait to
watch performance enhancing covers it
like you know peptides HGH so you can't
call HGH steroids or EPO steroid that's
what he's saying uh that's pretty badass
it's going down a dicey Road right so
say you do this and this guy destroys
the world record and then two months
later you know the actual real Olympics
the guy wins the gold and it's nowhere
near that guy's time it just I don't
know the enhanced games I'm sorry but
this [__] is going to be this this maybe
I'm naive but I feel like this this
would this may very well be the Maxim
magazine to other magazines remember
when that came out for we were like what
the [__] you know it's the same idea
it's like this is the kind of [__] dudes
want to we're all going to watch it like
okay so if you there's the games and all
of a sudden you go this guy shattered
Usain bolts record you got to see his
traps we're all gonna be like I gotta I
gotta watch this if they did enhan the
MMA I would totally watch that too so
yeah well you can just go back well you
can just just clock go back to UFC
whatever yeah I don't know how I feel
about I'm definitely I I want to watch I
just feel like it it screws over the
people who are natural you know no but
they're saying it like this is a
guarantee that everyone can do it so
there's no cuz people are they say
they're natural but they get caught you
know well first of all first of all I
think that within 5 years you're going
to just with Gene editing and all these
advancements it is inevitable that we're
going to have preder naturally large and
fast human beings it's going to be a
whole maybe 10 years but I almost feel
like it's like five is a little yeah I
almost feel like this is like let's get
ahead of the curve here I really do I
don't know then what happens if you know
people are just genetically modified
like then who's
special like LeBron was born that way
right obviously he's on stuff now but
when he's younger he was born that
way you don't think he's on HGH at 39
come on who cares he's still so talented
but yeah kind of it stops making people
special I mean now they can't catch and
throw and do certain stuff you know but
no I mean I I think that's been the
thing the question all along it's going
to be like who has the best doctors you
start with great genetics you got to
have a certain bone structure and
everything else but you know you're
going to be that like that's why
Christine dowa who created chrisper cast
n said we need a global pause on this
because you are going to get when your
kid when your wife is pregnant there is
going to be places you can go and
they're going to say how much fast
twitch muscle how long of a femur bone
this is what we recommend this is where
you get a 6'5 230 lb father I guess the
only thing is but you can't you can't
you can't program the heart like can't
program passion or heart or desire so
that's where it's going to well so so do
about so much of what we are as human
beings in my opinion is what we're
compensating for your shortcomings a lot
of times are what you try to overcome
which make you better it's like you know
I don't there's something about being
feeling awkward in your skin and having
insecurities that if navigated properly
inform your
self-expression is that's where funny
comes from that's where great art comes
from longing longing um yeah but I guess
to that point like if everybody's jacked
65 260 4% body fat runs up 44 in the 40
like that doesn't mean they can catch a
football that they have the heart to you
know show up to practice every day that
they're tough like you can't build
toughness it's just you're either born
with it or not but but then again if
you're built like DK metf and you are
you don't have to have as much heart as
say someone who you know you do he he
has heart that he's got heart
yeah I'm just saying if you're
physically DK mafs are out there that
never made it because they have no heart
they have no Drive they got caught up in
some [__] who knows yep so just
because there's a lot of guys can run a
44 and the 40 the majority of those
people aren't in the NL right so I don't
know I feel weird about it though I
would watch those Olympics I don't know
why baseball military I don't know why
oh military what are we doing those guys
should be on whatever it takes to defend
our freedom I think they are yeah yeah
what are we doing what are you gonna do
you know if you're if you're if you're
if you're in an elite I don't know why
baseball doesn't just do their thing uh
well yeah um just hitting a ball just
hitting a ball you protect protect your
product they can play longer baseball
players are thinner now than they were
in the 90s is that true thinner in other
words they're not as muscular as like
Jason back then guys I mean there's some
big dudes there's still some guys Aaron
is huge PES get all those pctures were
huge every one of those pitches were six
but I just don't get why they
don't let it let it ride I guess they
just don't want you know there's like
this taboo thinking from society with
when it comes to steroids but it's a
more entertaining product your players
can play longer they can throw faster
they can hit stay injury free longer
that's what I'm saying play
longer like there's no downside and
there's no there's no physical T like
we're not hitting each other no one's
running to each other I think it comes
down to I think it's the thing of you
don't want yeah you don't want to the
one one thing you love about sports is
that all things being equal we want to
see how they how they pit against yeah
but how crunk were you about the steroid
Olympics keep the same energy you just
want this is the direction we're heading
I'm I'm trying to keep my boner at
that's what I'm saying mid level mid
because I got tight pants on yeah dude I
mean I I can't wait cuz you know what
we're going to do but I think I think
when baseball does it but just you don't
need to announce it to the world like
they didn't announc Mark McGuire Samy SS
you know they didn't announce this to
the world it's just you just Sly you
know just tell the team not testing this
year just a little email blast hey
fellas not testing this year that's all
we do yeah I think I think what's going
to happen also is that the you're gonna
have these guys who are doing crazy [__]
on the field and stuff like that you
stop cussing for me sorry and uh then
then what's going to happen is we're all
going to be like wait what is he on
what's the cocktail what lab did you go
to I want some of that so so there's
going to be a huge play there's a big
money play on that whatever those
enhanced athletes are doing civilians
are going to copy that [__] I guarant
that's sorry civilians oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah everybody rich people
especially I want to look like that it's
already going on yeah I mean but now we
have now we have a a visible petri dish
where we have like these are mice in a
maze we're GNA just watch what really
works and it's been going on though if
you're privy to it it's been going on I
guess if those athletes are about their
their stack going to be doing this is
your stack now you're going to have
proprietary stacks and they're going to
keep that a secret probably my doctors
do this you know it's going to be they
don't want everyone knowing because then
the competition can use it so it's about
the best doctor going down a weird Road
it's going to be big business what it's
going to be oh yeah it's I mean it's
already a big business it's just not in
the mainstream might want to sign me
up you don't think I'm you know what you
are you're like when you um when you
build a car and you want to put like a
th000 horsepower on it you do it but the
rods the Pistons the drive shaft can't
support that power and then it breaks so
let's say we did it to you your bones
your tendons your your your KN they
can't they can't support the musle break
maybe I just want to walk around and be
like I I'm I got to get into a large my
back is too wide all I want is to do
this this is all I want right watch just
put on my put on my medium true classic
and all of a sudden I'm like this is too
tight isn't it and you guys go it's it's
obnoxious dude you to go large I got to
go large it's cuz my back I I'm not even
doing anything I was just that's fine
that's fine as long as you don't have to
like jog or jump in Jack come on bro I'm
I'm still I'm back to training MMA no
but I'm saying if we put all that
horsepower on you yeah the frames
not yeah you're yeah you you want to be
a th000 horsepower car but you're more
of a 200 horsepower car I just got
little short you don't have you don't
have the the insides for it I got short
femur bone what what really hurts my
feeling sometimes is when I'm on a plane
and I'm sitting next to somebody and
it's a lady and I look at my length of
my my femur bone which is what holds me
back in sport pretty good athlete I feel
it's kind of long standard it's not
short it's standard it's a little short
B it's a little short my Heights and my
torso on my neck we've talked about this
guys I I like to make things super
organic and natural does my skin look
good it's all right Ian it's shiny it's
all right it's because I got a lot of
Omega s fatty acids in me oh wow I was
wondering that this morning it's because
I'm always got a handful of macadamia
nuts is that why in the morning you look
so good from the nuts that's that's it's
the nuts or the nut milk I put the
Macadamia milk I put in my coffee
because it doesn't Spike my cholesterol
Etc uh House of macademia head over to
partner. House of academia.com
TFK now um you get free snack bars every
time with 15% off the whole order try
macadamia nuts they're really good for
you they got the chocolate cover crazy
dude that crazy guy who's trying to live
forever Brian Johnson he he swears by
macademia nuts apparently cuz he with
all the science apparently I don't know
that's what speaking
ofing Olympics yeah yeah yeah yeah he
looks he's he's downright translucent
that guy yeah now I'm not saying yourin
going to be yeah I'm not saying your
Skin's going to look like that but but
you can bundle up all sorts of goodies
and you get free macademia milk and free
shipping change up the macademia
subscription at any stage no strings
attached you can pause or cancel anytime
all you got to do is go to partner.
houseof macadamias
docomo don't look at that look at that
hey come on nope m a c a d a m i a s
nuts kiss these nuts what else you got
Jen all right we can't play this but I
just encourage everyone to watch this if
you haven't seen it already oh I can't
wait for this Fury versus us the trailer
the Traer now and then I want to get
your take on this going this fight's
February 17th same as the UFC I don't
know D I'm
um pretty sure it's February 17th yeah
yep good call so it's the same as the
UFC and what time is it on 10 a.m well
you know how you know how they do it
over there in Saudi when it says 10:
a.m. they probably won't fight
till because they like to do
performances and dance for the Chic or
whatever the hell the guy's name
is yeah MSB oh that's going to be a big
day are you in town on the 17th yes I am
ooh
I know we should probably do something
something something remember we talked
about the Kansas City we going talk
about that fight though yeah bro that's
we just want the fight thought you done
czy no man we had talked about that
fight we were just asking when the
official date is so it's on the 17th
yeah usk Tyson Fury can I see this
trailer you can't it's going to live
it's five minutes long it's good though
huh oh high production value it's a
movie trailer yeah it's basically a
movie it shows they're in the Wild West
go from Wild West to the col Pirates
incredible it's the best trailer you've
ever seen for a fight pretty much I mean
who direct is uh I mean he's just
incredible he's I I think he's I'm
putting my money on him he's a lot
smaller but I think he's gonna beat boy
if if yeah if the Tyson Fury that uh
showed up and fought Francis which it's
not going to be but if that even a
version of that comes out who's going to
beat the brakes off of him yeah I uh I
believe that uh usyk is hungrier and I'm
I'm interested to see what do you think
would you put your money on uh usk if
you had
to oh I mean you know I absolutely love
Tyson Fury so I wouldn't bet against him
no I love the Gypsy King yeah he's my
favorite by far the toughest fight of
his career by far really by far yeah so
with your heart but with your head I'm
I'm going usk I think usk's got I don't
know he's just what he wouldn't you see
that
Joshua God that version of of Tyson
against Francis
man and he he went right back in the
camp for usyk usyk's been trying to get
this fight for how many freaking years
now by far the toughest match up for for
Tyson wild can't wait though you just
hope they don't do what they did with
the the fury and uh Francis fight where
it's just all that crap
before you know they have dancing and
all that crap just a giant
spectacle same day you got UFC what is
that that's in Anaheim 298
wowski toia Robert Whitaker Paulo
Costo Jeff Neil in Gary what's your take
on all these what it's a little early to
give the the picks but yeah the great
that card's ridiculous yeah morab
Henry what a great day of fighting got
usk Fury going went down they got UFC
298 all about it that's up the street
too daddy that's in Anaheim want to take
a little Drive no no
no you want to go to the fights is Joe
gonna be calling him yeah man
he's well if he's calling him maybe we
go uh Mark just texted that it's
potentially off is that correct because
uh what F said what hold on let me
actually put this on
screen the fight of usyk Fury Fury's out
but then usyk is still in against
potentially someone else what why he got
hurt come
on oh wow Ty SP has suffered a cut in
training is out wow that's
sucks I don't care I only want to see
him fight I don't care could be several
months before Fury is ready to fight you
know what if you're a fury fan not the
worst thing in the world correct him
going from France to straight into this
Camp tough fight damn the trailer too
just came out that sucks D imagine if
you're the if you're the money behind
all the trailer promotion like what the
but you don't have usk fight another guy
just wait right n he'll fight he's a
fighters fighters He he'll fight he'll
beat the brakes off somebody all right
and he definitely wants that money from
that
place what if they announc Francis
versus
usk Fran fighting Joshua damn look at
this reportedly postponed let's hope
it's not like he calls him sausage I
think that's so funny to me and not
right sausage sausage it says usyk
vers
Philipe it's being explored yep dang
that's a bummer sausage damn literally
just you little sausage you little
sausage he says a lot of funny stuff
yeah yeah yeah that's such a bummer
again not the worst thing if you're
Francis or if you're a fury fan
severe cut wow man that's a bummer well
that bummed me out yeah what else you
got Jin yeah the Kansas City Chiefs fans
that froze to death all three of them
and their friend was inside the house
that slept for two days uh apparently
inside straight for two days straight
for two days that's why he wasn't able
to find them until later they died
already they did cocaine with fent so
they're saying Insider insiders are
saying that the initial toxicology
reports are saying they had fentanyl
that was Lethal level in them THC and
cocaine Jesus D these boys are trying to
party for the Chiefs game cocaine it
sounds like they did tainted cocaine
from insiders we're not 100% sure but
that's what they're
saying but that would make sense too if
if you're all that stuff you're like a
man cocaine who need the Blowfish got
busted with Coke was it Coke it said
like a minor drug offence that's our
friend right there Kate yeah she talk
smack on him
though who in the Blowfish
I like that guy yeah me too minor drug
offense nah he's good people man darus
Rucker came to my show in uh Phoenix
yeah no in uh Arizona Nashville
Nashville I like that
guy yeah yeah mean Kate aren't together
I like I like Kate I like both of them
yep what do we got busted
with possession of casual exchange
controlled substance so it could have
been anything
controled so it could even be like
vicadin or something you know
painkillers yeah not a big deal yeah I'm
sure he'll be okay I mean you know yeah
look the guy
party little something andish how many
more you guys want you think I don't
know man keep it going what time is it
right now I have a step class I have 952
just kidding give us uh one want one
more uh do you want do the Mark Norman
one not not really okay this is really
crazy this one that son sent this is so
insane so a
YouTuber allegedly killed his father who
he hated for some reason and then also
decapitated him and put on YouTube and
it lasted for like 14 minutes or so
before YouTube took it down there's like
that's a crazy image that's the his
dad's head
yeah can you go back to that I'm just
worried to put that on
screen oh okay cool well it's blurred
out though I'm well he's got he's
wearing gloves I mean and it's like in a
bag or something oh and by the way I
read that he boiled he stewed it into a
pot too yeah he sounds like he's uh you
know he needs some therapy yeah or
something that same right there it's
like let's start with the what happened
that shirt needs therapy well that that
shirt already is a red flag if you see
that guy walking in with that fake watch
and that that shirt that can cause a
child to go into a seizure what's Wild
is this was on YouTube for 14
minutes yeah [__] horrible man it's
just like some people people are so out
of their mind he clearly just he's he he
belongs in a hospital for the criminally
insane correction you YouTube Executives
eventually caught win so it was probably
on for a few minutes but it the video
was 14 minutes long oh keep going down
M you know why did do the head too but
don't ask why because there are no wise
you know what I'm saying now let's start
why did you uh oh oh why oh because see
what he did was you know there's
no I I don't know thought maybe his dad
took his PlayStation
Dad what's that he hated his dad I guess
other videos he kept talking about how
much he hates his dad you hate your dad
but cut his head off and then no he's
crazy he's a crazy person there are
other ways to deal with hate if you're
mad have a talk maybe write a letter I
don't know that's what I can't cut their
head
off it's where we draw the line
decapitation yeah yeah can get the who's
that so this is a a judge and two public
defenders um the judge posted this on on
their Facebook page he did okay okay
that's what I thought too right oh they
might be in a hot top on vacation guess
who the judge
is I don't know you would think it's the
dude but it's the black
girl yes and she posted to her Facebook
page and says Robson is surrounded by
great tatas but the actual word oh I
mean wait she's a judge she's a judge
and they're both District Attorneys
they're public defenders but but are
they on vacation in a hot tub it's yeah
they're having fun but the end of the
world it goes against the rules the code
that they can't hang out why you can't
oh you can't hang out like you know
stuff like that he's surrounded by great
tits I mean she's funny wow I I I'm fine
with it I'm fine with
humor so the rule is Jud the impression
that any person organization position
influence makes that's fair you Al yeah
me you're a judge man it probably again
again don't post these things like you
know what I mean just be a little bit
aware she also like she got she got in
trouble multiple times uh another time
is when she was talking to a defendant
and the the defendant was black and I
guess she she was tell the defendant did
something towards a cop she goes don't
ever be near cop wh you go don't get be
near cops because you're black and
they're you know they don't like black
people or something like that so she got
in trouble for that she sounds like she
just speaks her mind yes from the bench
I don't know if you want her being your
judge yeah she's let me go go back to
that again she's very pretty
there I don't know it's oh it's Las
Vegas too right is that where it's at
because every anything goes there that's
a different that's a different thing uh
all right I don't know sounds like she's
she sounds kind of fun yeah I don't know
if you want her as a judge though you
want want as you if you're on like trial
for murder like what was the uh what was
they were this yeah they must have been
on vacation or something I don't know
he's got I mean they're in a hot tub or
something but you don't it looks like an
indoor hot tub or it could be a sauna
yeah yeah like have some everyone's
thick in that picture they're
thick ain't nobody in shape you know so
they might be in the sauna sure cutting
weight maybe they're cutting weight
maybe they're just hanging maybe it's
like listen it's been a long time going
on yeah hey hey hey hey I don't I don't
get why this is a problem they can't
they have to hold themselves to a
certain standard you know you know who'd
be the worst enforcing any rules you and
me like I'd be like I mean well yeah
that's why I'm not a judge yeah I mean
not good multiple reasons yeah but
people don't think judges in these
District Attorneys don't like have fun
like normal people but don't post about
they come up as lawyers you know
probably were public defenders but even
her caption Robson is surrounded by
great tits someone's like hey man but I
I think it's funny I like that I like
the post you can't do it as a judge
though maybe as a judge a little bit
just know you're gonna get a little
they're gonna be like like K tomarrow
got a double murder trial she's pretty
though keep saying that this was her
other post like the initial post I think
in September where she actually wrote
this down on her life is still beautiful
despite the fact that Billy Alish
doesn't start for 30 minutes and I have
an 8:30 calendar tomorrow and then the
hashtag
vacate the [__] out of out of custody
cases where in the world's Carmen San
Diego it's just a vacate one that got
her in trouble yeah yeah she's a little
wild she's feisty yeah yeah I wouldn't
want her on my style you guys you guys
don't mind it but you want your but
let's say your kid was that's your judge
yeah but my my thing is yeah she's all
judges feel that way on the inside maybe
just hold it in maybe inside voice you
know inside Behavior yeah be
professional yeah all right here's that
last one cuz I got tagged so much in
this everyone's saying that this is
Brian 78 still going strong says this is
Bri you dude that's going to be me 100%
he's great though huh hell yeah he's
good looks he's he's an actual boxer
yeah he was he was boxer see his hand is
look at that right there 78 he looks
great yeah love that guy I actually
watch him he gives oh you do yeah he get
good oh he's like a guy like boxing aach
he's got a lot of aach followers oh
there there he is followed by col cond
oh yeah boxing coach yeah perfect he
he's like a TV journalist as well I
think he's awesome 78 I love a man like
that love him he's in good
shape that's me right there which one
can't wait to be 78 and still boxing
yeah he's moving well I get a little
insecure because I'm in an MMA class at
Jiu-Jitsu stuff with a bunch of 20 21
year olds and I I I feel a little bit
insecure sometimes I feel old CU I look
at myself in the mirror and I'm like
compared to 20y Old everyone says you
look great you've always heard this so
yeah yeah you know you should not guys
Louisville Comedy Club March one and two
and by the way Sam tripley and I at the
well in Bakersfield California Sam
tripley and I doing stand up Bakersfield
at the well February 23 yep it's
February 23 and then we're going to be
at the recck room February 24 in uh
Huntington Beach California so come come
check out me and Sam tripley it's
exciting Brian c.com for tickets I will
put that link up right away and we got
firing the kid live firing the kid live
in Austin Texas that is February 15th
Thursday night one show only with very
special guest yeah we'll see it's going
to be exciting come get some Austin all
right kids love you first one live we're
out
yeah